let's see if there's a way to make a
risk-free profit and let me just tell
you right from the get-go there's
usually not many ways to make a
risk-free profit in the world so this is
very theoretical if the spot price for
gold was a thousand dollars so the spot
price literally just means the market
price if you were to buy or sell gold
today and actually exchange hands then
you would pay or sell the gold four
thousand dollars per ounce and let's
also say that the one year forward
settlement price is twelve hundred
dollars per ounce so if you want to buy
gold one year from now you can agree
right now to buy it for twelve hundred
dollars or if you wanna sell gold one
year from now you can agree right now to
sell it for twelve hundred dollars by
entering into a forward or futures
contract and just the other details the
interest rate to borrow money is ten
percent and the carrying cost of gold is
fifty dollars per ounce per year the
carrying cost means if i had an ounce of
gold and i wanted to hold it responsibly
i wanted to store it maybe someplace in
a safe at a bank and i wanted to insure
it in case it got stolen or in case
someone lost it that would cost me fifty
dollars per ounce per year so that's
what we mean by carrying cost let's say
you could also invest money risk-free in
this type of a market i've just made up
these numbers for five percent a year so
how could you make the money
well you could and we're assuming you
start with nothing so you could
literally just borrow
you could
borrow one thousand dollars you borrow
one thousand dollars and then you use
that to buy an ounce of gold in the spot
market so you buy
you buy one ounce
of
gold and you also
agree to sell it in the future so you
also agree
agree so you enter into that forward
contract let me just write this way
enter
into
forward into forward as the seller as
the seller so you are on the spot market
you are the buyer and on the forward
market one year from now you agree to be
the seller so let's just think about how
this is going to play out
so over the course of the year
you will have some cost you will have to
pay the interest on this thousand
dollars that's ten percent so you're
gonna have to pay one hundred dollars in
interest and you're going to have to pay
the carrying cost fifty dollars per
ounce so
fifty dollars
carrying cost
carrying cost and so when we end up a
year from now you can sell
you will sell the gold so sell
you will sell the gold
four
for twelve hundred dollars
for twelve hundred dollars one year from
now and you know you can do that because
you entered into the forward agreement
and then you can pay back
pay
pay back the thousand dollars
the thousand dollar
loan
plus 100 interest
plus 100 interest and let's say you have
to pay the carrying cost at the end of
the year to the bank so plus the 50
carrying cost so how much did we how
much did we profit well we get 1200 and
we had to pay back
11.50 so we make so 1200 minus a
thousand minus a hundred minus fifty we
make a profit
we make a profit of fifty dollars so the
big takeaway here is
is that these type of things normally
don't exist if they did people would do
it all day and all night and this price
would go up because everyone would want
to buy on spot and this price would go
down because everyone would want to sell
in the futures market everyone would
want to do this right here so the
appropriate price is this one should not
this price based on these numbers right
here should not be any higher than 11.50
so the correct market price here if if
we didn't want risk-free profit or
essentially what the arbitragers would
make happen by by
kind of taking advantage of this it
would eventually go to 11.50 so it's
essentially the spot price
plus the cost to borrow money at that
spot price plus
plus the carrying cost so that's
essentially what would be the rational
price for the futures contract or the
forward settlement price